إذن ما قلناه مرة أخرى في
الاجتماع كان
أنه أه نعتقد أننا
نتوقع هو ما قلناه أن أه
الزيادات المستمرة في المعدل ستكون
مناسبة
أه والسبب أننا نحاول
تحقيق موقف سياسي مقيد بما فيه
الكفاية  لخفض
التضخم إلى 2 في المائة بمرور الوقت
ولا نعتقد أننا حققنا ذلك
بعد ، لذا قلنا إنك وأنا وأنت
تعرف الآن تقرير سوق العمل
وأعتقد مرة أخرى أن الظروف المالية
تتماشى بشكل أفضل مع  مما
كانت عليه من قبل ، لذا فإن الافتراض عندما
ألقيت خطابك كان أنه من المحتمل أن
بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي قد يفكر في
انخفاض الأسعار بحلول نهاية هذا العام ،
لم تعد الأسواق تفترض أنك
تعتقد أن الأسواق مخطئة
جيدًا ، لذا دعني أقول إن هذا أمر جيد.  كل
هذه الأرقام التي نطرحها
هنا مشروطة بالبيانات الواردة
وما يحدث لذلك لا نقول أبدًا أن
هذا هو ما نعتقد أنه سيحدث ، كما تعلمون
أننا نقوم بتوقع مبدئي
ثم ندع البيانات تأتي على سبيل المثال
إذا استمرت البيانات في الظهور بشكل
أقوى مما نتوقع وكان علينا أن
نستنتج أننا بحاجة إلى رفع أسعار الفائدة
أكثر مما يتم تسعيره في الأسواق أو بعد ذلك
قمنا بتدوين ذلك في مجموعتنا الأخيرة من
التوقعات في ديسمبر ، فسنقوم
بذلك بالتأكيد  من المؤكد أننا
سنرفع الأسعار أكثر